[Music]
so rob
my favorite favorite movie that you've
ever been in
probably one of my favorite movies
definitely one of my favorite books
is the hotel new hampshire
and i'm so curious
i listened to this podcast i read your
books
you never mention it why why why do you
not mention it it's the most brilliant
thing and you were so good in it and
so beautiful in it that's what i want to
know this is julie thanks rob
well julie it's so funny you say that um
i i literally just assumed nobody saw it
because it came out the same weekend as
splash
and nobody saw it
um but what's interesting about that
movie and thank you because i love it
and i'm really proud of it and and i
and i really liked the work i was doing
i was really young and
and there were everybody had such high
hopes for that movie
um it was as you alluded to a great book
a john irving book
it was my first really important movie
you know it's like a prestige project
every wanted everybody wanted to be in
it everybody wanted that part um tony
richardson won an academy award um who
directed it and you know it was a big
step from doing sort of teen comedies
and stuff which i
had been doing
um
and and then um you know
people didn't see it um but i love that
you love it and the other thing to think
about when you think about that movie is
that movie was a big summer studio
release
i mean if you really want to know how
much the movie business has changed look
no further than that the hotel new
hampshire
was an orion
movie okay it's basically about a
brother and sister who are in love with
each other
and end up sleeping with each other
who live in a crazy hotel
with a girl who wears a bear suit i'm
not making it up
summer blockbuster
thank you for the call